[Musica]
[Applauso]
albert einstein affermava che tutti
sanno che una cosa impossibile da
realizzare finché non arriva uno
sprovveduto che non lo sa e se la
inventò voi avete mai avuto dei sogni
ritenuti irrealizzabili io fin da
piccola ne avevo due volevo cercare di
cambiare il mondo e dedicarmi alla mia
più grande passione disegnare per
esprimere le mie idee dall'unione di
questi due è nato il fumetto sulle mafie
concepito per gli studenti di scuole
medie superiori come materiale didattico
il mio obiettivo era convincere i
ragazzi ad informarsi per poi
partecipare attivamente e difendersi
dalle mafie
era impossibile allora forse potevo
farlo così ispirata dalle parole di rita
borsellino giovanni tizian e tutti
coloro che si erano sacrificate di
impegnati nella lotta contro la
criminalità organizzata
decisi che avrei disegnato un fumetto
per i ragazzi con un linguaggio vicino a
loro per interessarli di più
il fumetto sarebbe andato nelle scuole
con l'obiettivo di dare una scossa al
sistema di innescare un cambiamento
il messaggio che volevo mandare era che
con il picco l'impegno di alcuni si
potevano informare mille menti quelle
menti che di conseguenza sarebbero
andate a stimolarne altre per poi
collaborare generazione dopo generazione
per costruire una società più sana e
meno corrotta quello che vorrei dire è
che se abbiamo un sogno un obiettivo da
raggiungere
basta solo impegnarsi più degli altri
per riuscire ad ottenerlo è solo una
questione di sacrificio ed impegno così
lavorando praticamente tutti i giorni
i ritagli di tempo molto scarsi ho
cercato di rendere il rapporto giovani
ricezione del messaggio il più chiaro
possibile
quindi ho preso i dossier tra la via
emilia e il west emilia romagna cose
nostre
dossier che trattavano di mafia in
regione e le estrapolati li ha
sintetizzati e ha selezionato una
comunicazione è facile da comprendere
una struttura semplice
questo era un processo che però mi
portava a fare e rifare le tavole
continuamente perché volevo rendere
sempre migliore
quindi cercavo di trovare immagini
sempre più dirette in modo che fosse più
capito così cercavo di rendere i volti
più espressivi e le azioni più dinamiche
perché più un lavoro d'effetto più ti
lascia qualcosa dentro e se l'artista
riesce con la propria opera a
trasmettere emozioni
allora può far scaturire nel cuore del
lettore un sentimento forte se questo
succede
l'artista ha raggiunto il proprio
obiettivo per non renderlo un lavoro
pesante ha inserito all'interno del
fumetto frasi umoristiche simpatiche
evitato di mettere all'interno lunghi
elenchi scolastici dando invece rilievo
a quei dati più allarmanti per far
capire ai ragazzi come quanto fosse
diffuso il fenomeno
i ragazzi hanno spesso fogli in mano con
date di informazioni sono vestiti alla
moda e hanno un forte spirito di
iniziativa
tutto questo studiato per coinvolgerli
meglio anche i colori sono studiati per
gran parte del fumetto troviamo tavole
nere graffiate di bianco sfondi neri e
in questo caso sfondi scuri caotici
rappresentano l'immoralità della mafia e
queste sono tavole che vanno pian piano
a schiarirsi in quelle vignette dove i
ragazzi decidono di riflettere
e di passare all'azione i personaggi
sono tutti i gatti in questo fumetto
proprio perché ai ragazzi generalmente
piacciono molto gli animali e mai come
in questo periodo c'è un'esplosione di
empatia verso gli animali domestici
l'ultima pagina è la pagina più
personale e decisiva del fumetto è
quello che lascia il compito il libero
arbitrio e quella che riassume il senso
del progetto che vediamo in queste
parole volete un mondo più pulito
datevi una mossa fin lo decidi tu e
quasi chiude il fumetto con una vignetta
all'aria aperta dove ci sono i ragazzi
con un sorrisone pronti a darsi da fare
che detto in termini adulti sta nel non
è detto che per forza le cose che non
vanno non possono cambiare basta solo
darsi da fare ogni giorno con impegno e
forza di volontà
così dopo notti passate a cercare di
modificare le tavole fino a renderle
perfette sono riuscita a farlo
pubblicare il fumetto è stato pubblicato
in due edizioni una appunto prevede il
processo emilia il fumetto è stato
utilizzato come strumento di
sensibilizzazione da insegnanti
attivisti ed associazioni che hanno
organizzato iniziative a scuola e serate
a tema in regione nelle scuole è stato
distribuito in 109 classe è stato
distribuito in alcune biblioteche ed i
volontari interessati riassunto questo
voglio dire che è possibile respingere
una mentalità basata sul disinteresse
verso temi importanti semplificando la
realtà rendendola comprensibile
coinvolgendo in questo progetto
insegnanti studenti attivisti per poi
farli collaborare per respingere quella
mentalità dei rapporti di forza che si è
andata a creare in questa società che va
dal bulli
alla malavita
in tutto questo processo sono cambiato
anch'io perché so che posso raggiungere
qualsiasi obiettivo
basta solo impegnarsi e condensare tutto
nello spirito di sacrificio
ciò che però veramente mi ha dato la
forza
in tutto questo percorso è stato vedere
le reazioni dei ragazzi è stato molto
molto molto emozionante vedere ragazzi
sorridere mentre vedevano gatti parlare
di mafia riuscire a capire quello che
stavano leggendo incamerando senza
fatica e da queste piccole cose che si
trova la forza queste piccole cose che
diventano sempre più numerose fino a
poter cambiare la società
grazie
[Applauso]